good evening Colonel Brian here and we
are broadcasting once again from my home
in Los Angeles when I say we I mean me
no one else really except this bust of
Teddy Roosevelt which is I'm sort of
like Tom Hanks and that's my that's
Wilson the volleyball just I talk to him
all the time once I misplaced him and I
was like dad good guy anyway we're all
losing it we're all doing the best we
can to get through this one of the
things I miss oh by the way check this
out look at that sexy lock of hair
single lock of hair coming down across
the forehead pretty pretty sexy right
anybody nobody I don't know I like it
just right there look at that I don't
know just
that's one extension that I bought but I
put in it's getting a little get a
little crazy here Oh strange these are
strange times I'll be honest with you I
missed some things I miss coming out of
the top of the show and telling jokes
you know it's hard to tell jokes when
there's no audience here there's no one
here to laugh one way to do it of course
is with my old friend Andy Richter my
sidekick I love when Andy laughs at my
jokes and so I thought hey let's
recreate that magic
I'll tell some jokes Andy will laugh on
zoom' right easy
the problem is Andy has really crappy
Wi-Fi so what we did we tried this once
before didn't work out great we're
trying it again is we're having Andy
pre-record his reactions to monologue
jokes that way I'll tell the joke we'll
cut to a prerecorded of an e laughing
and I think we're gonna be in good shape
we'll get that old rhythm back Teddy
likes it alright let's get into it let's
see what the writers cooked up hey check
this out critics say that one reason
president Trump's ratings are cratering
right now is that he's not good at
showing empathy yeah
the other reason of course is that he
wants us all to die
I'll drink to that perfect yeah right
right Andy
hello Burbank Fire Department I'd like
to report a third-degree burn yeah hey
check this out Carnival Cruise is in the
news Carnival Cruise announced they're
gonna start offering cruises again as
early as August that's right yeah
Carnival is gonna offer a three classes
of service economy premium and extra
Cove it'd howing a ding ding a ding a
ding ding ding dong all right okay hey
everyone's missing sports everyone wants
their sports right now check this out
the South Korean baseball league has
started back up again that's right the
players are playing in front of an empty
stadium yeah yeah after hearing this the
San Diego Padres said hey that's our
idea you know I thought the dress looked
black and gold hmm all right hey well
this is in the news a new studies show
that the corona virus cannot I repeat
not be transmitted through sex yeah
unless of course like me your fetish is
to be coughed on during sex man wears a
plumber when you need one okay all right
we're all gonna have okay well anyway